hello and welcome to this video will
play d-ball Matata okay we gotta
accelerated dragon okay so he plays for
peace play not the more oxy bind it's a
funny line that recently became popular
okay just cancelled short not trying to
refute it in any way
yeah f4 it's maybe a little bit more
interesting than usual now that look is
away from the f7 on often times you can
just take and played Bishop c6 and now
he five becomes a little bit more
dangerous than
yeah definitely so if you take the
bishop cheeks I play something else
entirely okay so completely useless to
spend the minute if five was interesting
taking nd5 this is now just I think okay
for black okay i can go Knights you form
yeah i think this is probably helpful ok
so what a really short maybe a4a seven
could have been taken to I'd seen
beehive be wise as an idea here not sure
that looks okay I thought taking an
active site was maybe interesting but
then be to hang seng ok so I'm opening
this up
make sure of is really hanging on a
seven were to a 4s desirable anyway mmm
get if 1584 ever take Bishop cheeks it's
actually doable do wrong I've got ok and
then 95 as he actually had an idea with
King edge wanna actually should have
paid a bit more attention that I was
just not seeing this idea I had quinsy
five before and now that this work ok
yeah
okay so I'm taking one see tool doesn't
work yeah I probably have to do this now
generally can take new take on them f6
which it takes at five is an idea though
I take with this maybe I'm not losing
the F pawn then it looks pretty dry
actually I will not sure how does he
cover all this now slide the play here
and I take the Jeep on I mean maybe he
can just allow me to take it or he's
trying so he allows me to check it
Jeff check so winning this and now for a
three-time warning it doesn't do much
actually I unfortunately draws that
which is a bit of a shame but okay it's
what it is Graham our third game drunk
galitsin it's a bit of a disappointment
there I thought I might might get
somewhere so yeah this is probably
roughly equal F Phi I was thinking about
'if i hear more that that was more what
I was worried about um i wasn't i want
to show actually I was thinking this
this and then he five but I can do this
I did played this immediately it doesn't
seem so critical that i didn't i didn't
play it right it seems i mostly I'm
think I'm quite ok up to here but that
yeah that really was a saying that that
made sense this move I should now move
the Queen as the engine suggest Queen d7
also knowing this is a little bit yeah
and just yeah i was thinking i can take
cannot look be one Queen c4s was by
calculation and that's on and foreigner
that's true actually can't hear you
probably just has to be more precise the
attics here and you get six okay yeah
yeah but it's get it will get to you
sometimes if you just play every move
basically immediately unfortunately I
couldn't Bend again I hear you probably
cannot win yeah now you get this format
the a porn is probably too strong okay
HH to let it gives a little bit better
chances you have an eldest son okay too
yes trolley wins I know the engine i
left didn't switch it on sorry the
engine says black winsford sometimes I'm
skeptical now probably that's true okay
I draw at the end thanks for watching